d'attention public était déjà apparu le
mois dernier à l'occasion de la dernière
plénière de la collectivité territoriale
de martinique il ya non plaisir chef de
file de bas pays en chance et marinette
tant pis élu du même groupe reprochant à
megan laventure son inertie dans la
gestion de certains dossiers des deux
entreprises
mais vendredi dernier lors de leur
réunion mensuelle
les élus de bas pays en chansons franchi
un nouveau pas en incluant le secrétaire
général des forces martiniquaises de
progrès moi ce que je sais c'est que les
porteurs de projets ne sont pas
satisfaits ce que je sais c'est que les
porteurs de projets se plaignent comment
voulez-vous me dire que l'on interdit au
personnel de la collectivité de donner
des réponses aux porteurs de projets sur
l'état d'avancement de leur projet ça
n'est plus supportable
il faut que miguel laventure se met au
travail
il faut qu'au milieu de l'aventuré ne
soit plus dans le déni il ne faut pas
quand on lui dit que ça ne va pas qu'ils
lisent donc tout va bien
le chef de file de bain payant chance
qui demande au passage au président de
l'exécutif d'agir de 7 et lula qui ne
remplit pas sa mission qui ne fait pas
son travail qui ne répond pas aux
attentes des martiniquais que cet élu là
il faut que le président de l'exécutif
et je le cite encore une fois alfred
marie-jeanne l'obligent à faire sont à
remplir sa mission dans un communiqué
miguel laventure souligne que nul ne
peut l'exclure d'un groupe qui n'est pas
un parti politique
bah pays en chance ce n'est pas un parti
politique
tous ceux qui ont été élus au titre de
cette liste sont automatiquement des
élus bas payant chance
rien ni personne ne peut en décider
autrement
je ne changerai pas mes priorités après
les dissensions au sein du mime 7 à
présent l'autre chez nom de l' alliance
majoritaire qui s'effrite à moins d'un
an d'échéances électorales majeures